Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and you
can call anytime you want. The number is two
one nine two David P.. I've essentially stopped
playing any voicemails from Troyes, York, but
and he calls like four or five times a day. But I
want to play this voicemail because it relates to
something really, really sinister that's going
on. It relates to vaccines. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: David Pakman, how many videos
are you? Are you in the lying media
going to continue to put out about people who
are anti who's getting sick and dying and covid?
And why don't you put out videos of the numerous,
just more numerous, most likely of people who have
received the vaccine and then they drop dead
within a week to a month? And the cover up of
these this number actually is much higher.
But there are stories where they actually
pinpoint the deaths of people through.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this is this is totally
made up. So there's two things that are going
on here. One, when you give tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people a vaccine and you
start with the oldest and most vulnerable folks,
by sheer math, some number of those people
are going to die because people die.
And then to attribute it to a vaccine when we have
no reason to think the vaccine had anything to do
with it doesn't make sense. The second thing
that Troy may be referring to is that there's
a vaccine side effect reporting system called
Vassar's. And maybe I'll do a story about this
virus or Veirs, I believe it's set in
shorthand, is being targeted with massive
dumps of bogus vaccine, side effect and deaths.
Submissions, anti vaccine are going to the Veirs
system and just making up submissions. And then
anti VAX publications are taking that bogus data
and putting out reports on that
basis. It's a major problem.
Maybe we'll do a segment on it. But as usual,
Troyes or completely divorced from reality.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up it. Join Caplan dot com. I'll see you then.